One of the things that the Auschwitz
guards used to do to the prisoners,
and this is very telling,
so at Auschwitz there was a sign that
said work will make you free.
It was a little joke.
Not really a very funny joke,
you know,
it's the kind of joke that you have to
be,
say tannic is the appropriate term to
conceptualize and to dare to
due to state.
So when now our sweats prisoners came to
Auschwitz,
you know,
they're already pretty,
pretty rough shape.
They were in cattle cars.
They'd been separated from their
families.
Everything had been taken from them.
They were transported for a long time.
They were standing up,
the kids were suffocating because there
was no room in that,
you know,
it was so packed in there.
They didn't have anything to eat.
There weren't any toilet facilities of
any sort.
It was like you got rid of 20 percent of
the people just transporting them,
you know the ones on the outside of the
cars,
they froze to death because of course it
was cold and pretty nasty.
And then when they got to Auschwitz,
the guards used to have this game that
they would play.
This is part of the work will set you
free thing.
They would get a prisoner,
they take a prisoner who's already in
pretty pretty rough shape and then have
them carry a sack of wet,
sold 100 pounds from one side of the
camp to the other.
And you know,
when you think of a camp,
you think of something like a football
field,
you know,
maybe something that big fences around.
It's like,
no way man,
these were cities.
These were,
there were tens of thousands of people
in these places.
So from one side of the camp compound to
the other,
that was a good hike and that wasn't bad
enough.
They had to get them to carry it back
and put it in the same place.
Now that's poetic and it's malevolence.
You know,
what you're doing is you're harnessing
the human compulsion to engage in useful
activity and demonstrating how
absolutely futile that is despite its
difficulty,
seems like a bad thing to do.
People need.
It's a parody of meaninglessness.
That's what that is.
And you know,
people need meaning in their lives
because their lives are difficult.
And so the question is to what end
should you devote your life?
And another question might be,
well,
does it matter?
Matter is an interesting word,
a because matter is matter,
but matter is also what matters.
And I would say that what matters is
more real than matter.
At least that's how you act.
And then the question is,
well,
is there something you should be aiming
at?
That's a good question.
That's the question of the meaning of
life.
And you know,
one of the things that supposed to
happen when you come to university is
that that's the sort of question that
should be addressed.
And as far as I can tell,
and this might just be my more cynical
side,
what I see happening to university
students generally speaking,
is that they come in clinging to the
wreckage of their culture and floating
with the pieces.
And those pieces are taken away by
professors who tell them that everything
can be deconstructed and no,
nothing has any real meaning.
And it's like when you're finally
educated,
it's when you're floating out on the
ocean and you've got nothing to stay
afloat with.
It's like,
well then you're,
you're done.
And you congratulate.
And it's like,
I don't see that as useful.
Quite the contrary.
So let me tell you a story.
The first thing I'm going to propose to
you,
and we'll talk about this a lot,
is that you inhabit a story that the
framework through which you look at the
world is actually a story.
And here's the story.
The story is you're somewhere and you're
going somewhere and even that can be
conceptual or whatever.
It's the,
but there's a gradient between where you
are and what were you aiming at,
which means no more really than you're
doing something.
Well,
you're sitting there and hypothetically
you're aiming for something better and
so you're in a state of insufficiency.
Oh,
is the DNS insufficiencies change?
And then you're trying to rectify the
insufficiency and you presume that your
current state is less preferable to the
state that you're aiming at.
And then the way that you bring those
two together is sometimes you can do it
through thinking,
but fundamentally you do it through
action.
You do it through acting in the world.
And so that's sort of,
that's sort of the answer in some sense
to the mind body problem.
You have a conceptual structure,
but when you implement it,
you're,
you're implementing it,
not abstract,
but you're implementing it through
action.
And so that's,
that's the basic story.
It's not a very interesting story,
but it's the framework through which you
view the world.
So it's a value laden framework,
otherwise you wouldn't be able to act
and you wouldn't know what to look at.
So it's a value laden framework.
You look at the world through a value
laden framework.
So then we might say,
well,
what is the optimal Value Laden
framework?
That's what we're going to try to figure
out.
Now I told you about the war that went
on between the communists in the West
and how that obsessed me.
And so one of the things that I really
wondered about was what was this just an
arbitrary thing?
You know,
like did the Communists,
they had some axioms and we had some
axioms and if you're a moral relativist,
you might say,
well,
who's to say which set of axioms are
better?
Or even who's to claim that?
You could say that a set of actions one
set is better than another.
That's a moral relative,
this claim and Puno Fair enough.
So I thought,
well maybe this is just an arbitrary
thing and it's going to be settled by
force because that's how you settle an
arbitrary claim between two competing
systems where there's no room for
negotiation.
So I thought about that for a long time.
I wanted to know what the roots were of
the Marxist system and what the roots
were of the Western system.
And what I surmised was that the western
system was actually something that
evolved.
Whereas the communist system was a
rationalist construction that was
imposed and they weren't the same thing.
And so then I wondered,
well,
what's western culture grounded in and
is there any reason to assume that
that's real in any sense?
And so that's what took me into this
study of the underlying stories.
The fundamental stories upon which our
culture,
I believe is based in some of those are
very old.
I'm going to tell you a Mesopotamian
story.
It's one of the oldest stories we know
I'm going to tell you an Egyptian story.
Those are sources of our culture and I
think those stories are grounded in much
older traditions and I think they refer
to something real actually real.
Now,
I already told you that there are
different ways of conceptualizing real
and that my initial hypothesis,
presumption,
axiom you might say,
is that pain is the most real,
and the reason I believe that is because
that's how people act.
Now you can criticize that.
You can certainly come up with an
alternative conceptual framework which
the scientists have because they believe
that the most real thing is mattered.
Maybe we need more than one set of tools
to operate in the world.
It's possible.
So now I want to tell you what I think
the fundamental constituent elements are
of stories,
and one of the things that I hope is
that this knowing this will make you
immunize,
immunize you against ideology.
And the reason,
because I believe that ideology is our
fragmentary metanarratives narratives,
and they have their power because
they're grounded in the Meta narrative,
but they only tell of the story,
but they have power because they're
grounded in the fundamental narrative.
And so here's the fundamental narrative
as far as the characters,
let's say we're going to say that people
are prone to characterize the world or
social primates.
We're social cognitive primates,
so we tend to see the world through the
lens of a social creature and so and
partly because we're concerned with
acting in the world and the world is
mostly other people.
Then we conceptualize the ground of that
structure for action in
characterological terms.
So the most fundamental reality is chaos
and chaos is what you don't understand
it all.
You can't even conceptualize it.
You,
you come into contact with it in bits
and pieces.
When the twin towers fell,
when the twin towers fell,
chaos reigned for a few days.
Everyone was shellshocked and that was
chaos.
And Chaos is what you experience.
When your story falls apart,
and that's a descent to the underworld.
That's chaos.
And basically you live in order,
in chaos and order is where when you do
what you think you should do,
what you want to have happen happens,
that's ordered,
that's explored territory and chaos is
when you do what you're supposed to do
to get what you want and it doesn't
happen.
And then that place that you're
magically in.
When that happens,
that's chaos and it has different depths
you could say it reaches all the way to
hell,
and that usually happens when your life
falls apart very badly,
and you're down in that chaos and you
realized that it was your fault and that
you did something wrong and that you
knew it and you ignored it.
That's the worst form of chaos.